so it's really like I think part of the
really important part of the process of
package life cycle and package
development is not just adding new
functions but it is equally important to
remove those functions
and we know that removing functions that
used to work is frustrating
and so we have developed this process
this life cycle process of deprecation
where it starts with pretty mild
warnings and kind of gets progressively
aggressive more and more aggressive over
time we hope this is useful we hope that
this kind of gradually pushes you to
towards the golden path without like
forcing you uh rudely when you're
working on something else to urgently
switch something but at the same time we
believe that we want these functions to
be better we want these things to have a
more consistent cohesive syntax because
that makes it easier for future users
and I I think we're doing pretty well uh
We've certainly got a lot better I think
at handling deprecations and breakages
but we're certainly you know still
trying still learning and uh if you have
any feedback please let us know